[Music]
Ansel every opens up news open up about
what 0:01 slivery liberté submitted by
two cups one bar that we grows that's
the one what the ladies are [ __ ] on
it but that would be two cups one you so
you're just [ __ ] bottles one Bart
it's like fine but through that water
bottles one bar yeah I just guess yeah I
did - Emilia Clarke from Game of Thrones
opens up about undergoing two brain
surgeries to correct aneurysms
oh my during the filming of Game of
Thrones opened up on social media
she we're not sure what's going through
her surgery she wrote an essay for The
New Yorker and she was talking about her
health problems that started in February
2011 right after these they ran filming
the first season of Game of Thrones Ohio
was just starting so she was working out
with her trainer in London when she
liked her trainer made her do this plank
position and that's when she immediately
felt an elastic band that was squeezing
her brain and then she she tried to
ignore the pain and just pushed her it
through it but then she couldn't so she
told her trainer that she needed to take
a break and somehow thank God it wasn't
barbed arts like [ __ ] no that's normal
you're supposed to feel I should keep
pushing I actually think maybe I had an
aneurysm in my past are you serious no
because I remember back in the day ders
I had two really insane headaches before
when I was training and uh this is back
later to Bally's days and I remember
lifting my head was like hurting like
crazy and then I just thought that that
was my body trying to be a [ __ ] at the
time saw so I'm gonna do like five more
sets you know she says well do 83 more
reps there's a lot of people that die
from these types of aneurysms and the
people that don't die they need to have
immediate surgery oh then you didn't
have so I was being my [ __ ] I'm glad
you showed
yes yes so then she said like she was
almost crawling to the locker room she
reached to the toilet
she started violently throwing up and
then that the pain was shooting stabbing
and constricting pain it was just
getting worse oh my god and then at some
point she just she knew that her brain
was damaged and then she says that she
remembers a woman asking her she was
okay and then the next thing she
remembers is sirens ambulance sirens and
[ __ ] and you're such a big boy sirens is
she I didn't realize it came out so I'm
like [ __ ] you want it then I gave it
to you boom yeah yeah I didn't notice a
difference because no it's great I just
heard sirens he's beautiful it's the
sound of LA yeah yeah yeah so then uh
she was rushed to the hospital and then
she was sent for an MRI and then during
that that's when they found out that she
had a sub of chronic or annoyed I'm even
tried sah type of aneurysm
life-threatening type of stroke caused
by bleeding into the space surrounding
the brain it's scary
yeah so then that's what she said like
later on she learned that a third of saw
patients died immediately or soon there
I am she's a queen do she's for real a
Khaleesi
yes and then those that survive they
need urgent treatments to seal off that
aneurysm she can't die until the
season's over the whole it is now it is
now imagine she dies no I don't want her
told you see remember she couldn't die
from the egg no spoilers here my boy
season one spoilers there's a pretty
early season I've never sold yet and see
it everybody start watching it next week
I actually actually got HBO on Hulu just
for it okay it's like
shall do it's such a good [ __ ] you want
you know I'm like shut up wait what a
minute damn I say is it drama or so like
action uh so it's both and it's really
tight because like it's all of the
important roles are [ __ ] female and
bad as [ __ ] I think you'll like it I
love it I think you'll like don't get
discouraged by the whole fact that it's
like [ __ ] the Old English and I don't
know let's just
I hate those periods you don't like it
but I love Game of Thrones really
everybody loves Game of Thrones like I
don't know people the best show ever
made so far people also have always said
that about Harry Potter oh I love Harry
Potter right and you must it's on Harry
made so even Thrones do you want to
rewatch eye shadow how long are the
episode 1 hour I could do but they're
like a movie there's a lot of season but
there may like a movie you watch a
couple and you're gonna be hard if you
have to watch 3 at least there make sure
you lose a lot of setup but it's really
why does he want to watch it cuz he's so
like it's not a movie yeah
he just has that mindset yeah even
though a lot of series are better than
movie that I know but he's trying to
open up in our writing in our writing
things he's trying to open up and he's
like it's hard to watch serious though
sometimes because they drag a state
dragon it's [ __ ] series there
are some that dragon some of them we can
top this state consistently good the
whole life yeah so it's very like even
some of my favorite series they'd be
dragged and I guess I just finished it
just to finish it his main thing to his
problem with TV shows is that he hates
how people act in TV shows he's like no
one act like that in real life but I'm
like it's the world that they painted
just dive into that world this is a film
guy that's why he likes food you've ever
films like if they don't act like a real
person did you just watch blogs if you
want some watch real people are probably
worse than that he's like what he wants
real people yeah but that's not vlog
those laws are people are never real
we're pretty [ __ ] real yours are
pretty real you like to draw he likes to
like really feel like those human
emotions no but see love but you're
still performing to camera you don't
ever talk I never said you talked to a
human being like that alright that's why
because I love my camera longing is
still an art United mean you still have
to perform to the camera as TV needs to
watch surveillance footage exactly see
CCTV
okay see what a loved it he would have
loved the [ __ ] k-town the silver a
black car yeah she wrote this essay to
kind of bring awareness to the whole
thing so that was the first one right so
then during that procedure it was
minimally invasive so they didn't have
to like open her up or anything but they
found that there was another aneurysm it
was like right on the verge why should
not so many of those things right I
don't know we don't know then that first
one was a three hour surgery by the way
so uh she said like the recovery wasn't
bearable and it was just the worst and
then they told her about that second one
that could burst and then she was in the
hospital for a short time she was able
to continue working and so later on she
had to go in a second time like for that
second surgery to fix that other one
that they told her because it was
getting like it was had doubled in size
oh when they checked her again and so
that one they had to like open her up
and stuff and see she said that the
entire time like the entire recovery
process she was in so much pain and it
got to the point where she was just
telling the nurses and like doctors I
just kill me like I can't just let me go
and so she went through a lot she
suffered a lot of anxiety and panic
attacks and and so she spent a month in
the hospital
second time but then she continued to
did all that while filming and promoting
the show - yeah so she created a charity
the reason why she wrote this essay was
because she created a charity called
same you and it's to raise money for
people recovering from brain injuries
and stroke and so she came out with this
because she said it was just time and
she was just she she said that she said
quote there's something gratifying and
beyond lucky about coming to the end of
Thrones I'm so happy to be here to see
the end of this story in the beginning
of whatever comes next because she
really thought that she was gonna die do
brain aneurysms aneurysms are the same
like I meant to the store before my
friend had one but my brother I just
remember my brother told me that there
was a measure of it was his friend or
not but there was somebody in high
school that had a brain aneurysm and you
know like a lot of Asian parents they
just when you have like serious panic I
just brush it off yeah but this person
he had a brain aneurysm and they didn't
really know and it was killing him like
and he must have already had like
suicidal thoughts but he ended up
blowing his brains out so that's why
when you when she said you know like I
just wanna dis [ __ ] kill me that's
probably what he was going through but
he literally offed himself at his
parents wouldn't take him to the
hospital
have you guys ever been in so much pain
that you're like I rather just [ __ ]
do working out with this wolf we were
just doing calf raises to Jeff Kiyomi
just holding onto a curtain and I died
from and you're a brain aneurysm - do
you feel like your brains just gonna
explode because of the pressure maybe
probably I had this one pain I told her
about it um it was like maybe six months
ago I was showering at the JK office and
I'll just take a shower all of a sudden
I like this crazy pain like right here
and I just collapse on the floor
wow what the [ __ ] is going on and then
and they never happened after oh you
don't get a check no I thought if I was
your appendix then it would have it yeah
it's Peters so random to us when I
thought I had a hernia [ __ ]
like what type like this are like it
like a sharp needle pain and I'm like
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] it was like a crazy
crap maybe or you could have but it just
slides it'll s um maybe like 30 seconds
there's a long time oh oh I'll get hurt
like crazy that tears coming out I'll
just lay it on the bathroom at the JK
office the water running when I thought
I had a hernia I thought my [ __ ] was
[ __ ] turns out that I just had really
weak abdominals and I was doing boy Tai
and I just tore an abdominal doing kicks
just going ham on kicks just got and
then I just tore it up down that web
West birth stop painful
I'm c-section nervous yeah I was drugged
but like I did feel some contractions
and that was like well how many
centimeters were you when you felt them
I was maybe dilated one like I was small
to jam and it was every day okay it was
bad
uh no it was really bad but not to the
point where I wanted it kill myself
right where you're just like what's
coming at the coming uh no it was just
really painful and like my I wanted to
throw up and like your body just gives
up it was Wow
but not like what she described
[Music]
[Music]